[Music]
come on Ben
take a free pointer what are you afraid
of oh right the fact that it definitely
won't go in this guy talks more trash
than a young Kobe it also takes more
bird shots than the old one least I'll
take shots penny one point alright just
roll some of us actually have real games
to play rude or fake the person enjoyed
the line for that's a turnover Oh
mistakes like that can cost you Squire
the year but I guess you can always try
again next year whose turn is it
I think its faults Europe and I thinks
I'm not ready what's happening here why
you got the new one guy yeah just came
out but it's the owner this season well
they've got a handcar for the graphics
Lanza how is it it's pretty realistic
except they made my hair look painted on
that's because it does look painted on
Oh sis Mona Lisa over here well can I
see mine sure let me find it it's Gordon
Haywood Derrick Rose klay Thompson whoa
graphics are uncanny ah here you go
Santa Lanza oh thanks I think wait I
think that's Michael carter-williams
very funny
londo your ratings actually pretty solid
but what about mine you know this
doesn't look anything like me I guess
they're all lazy total Burke of the
drift well what's my writing 272 what
I'm a 72 in lonzo's and 80
weren't you in a bloody egg last year
yeah but it was like a special magical
thing it's probably changed it's just
that we haven't got the update Raven why
don't you just create your own night huh
I suppose I should oh one of those those
are your default wonky boots you start
with them now hey little me can't be
seen in these come on now you can
purchase swag for your character from
Ronnie 1k over there but I warn you it
gets expensive but 500 covers for boots
that's madness well you can't put a
price on style I'm gonna fancy get me
character don't start without me all
right hey you Ronny 1k that's right firm
oh yeah well I'd like to try out some of
your haircuts please no samples you try
you bye come on
well then I'd like your finest fur coat
for my lizard night that'll be 100 BC
what's
see virtual Karpis okay here 90 these
are real coppers we only take virtual
coppers within how do I get virtual
coppers you pay me real coppers are you
right so can I get 100 virtual coppers
there you are
it's empty well that's because you just
went and spilled them all over the floor
in bounds Alonso what do I do
first cool what you move you're on a
team with Koos and Donovan marquel you
ready no okay I'll send a full court
pass to Mitchell all right roll for it
okay now I've picked up all 100 of my
virtual coppers off the floor and I'm
handing them to you please give me the
fur coat nice try what you're free short
so after the battle you run into Matt
Barnes he asks you if you'd like to join
him on a 95 mile quest to kick Derek
fish's ass do you say a violence is
never the answer or be but sometimes it
is Oh seven houses are so boring
can we skip this nope sorry according to
the rules you can't skip the would
cutscenes alright
pure sharp demigod alpha dog with
limitless range y'all a barbecue chicken
damn coos and it only cost me twenty
thousand coppers and three me goats or
Artoo's get in faults the game is almost
over you sure you don't want to sub in
okay I'm ready
has he put up Jimbo top of the key oops
alright it's my fault
two points away from the wind I want to
dunk over Ben Simmons you know I'm a wee
bit taller than given heart right we'll
find out real quick boom 18 I win
who says I'm not Squire the Year
actually know you miss on an 18 yeah I
mean your donk rating it says here your
donk ratings only 15 a leader or a 22
pull up a stunt like that what I talked
to mine or I won the
don't count I still haven't received an
update hey Ronnie fix your bloody 1k
server Raven so bit by the time that
update gets here I've already won Squire
of the year may I just mentioned that
I'm the third leading scorer on the
second-best house in the East despite
devastating injuries to our finest
Knights I think that deserves some
consideration well if either of your
houses were in the West you wouldn't
even be considered for Squire of the
Year stop your squabbling children the
term Squire of the Year award is
overrated by this time next year nobody
will even remember who won oh yeah
and who the hell are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]